hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
Basic Pizzateig Rezept auf dieses Video
könnt ihr immer zurückgreifen wenn ihr
Bock habt auf eine richtig leckere
italienische Pizza der Teig besteht aus
nur vier Zutaten ich lege direkt los und
schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben hier unten in die Infobox
und ich habe jetzt erstmal lauwarmes
Wasser und da Brüssel ich jetzt frische
Hefe hinein ich gebe euch auch in diesem
Video ganz viele Tipps und Tricks die
ihr beachten könnt um wirklich den
perfekten Pizzateig zu bekommen diese
Rezept habe ich vor ich glaube 4 Jahren
oder so rausgefunden durch
Experimentieren auf was muss man achten
damit es wirklich perfekt wird und
deshalb gebe ich das jetzt an euch
weiter so das ganze dass ich hier einmal
schön auflösen und da kommt jetzt direkt
Mehl mit rein ich nehme jetzt Pizza Mehl
das ist Typ 0 0 und dann könnt ihr auch
schon das Salz mit reingeben und dann
einfach mit den Händen zu einem schönen
homogenen Teig zusammenkleben
so ihr habt jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder gebt ihr den Teig jetzt für
zwei Stunden an einen warmen Ort ich
habe den Teig jetzt auch schon halbiert
weil es kommt zwei Pizzen raus und so
kann jeder teig noch mal separat
aufgeben die noch ein bisschen Mehl oben
drüber und dann werde ich das mit
Frischhaltefolie komplett luftig
schließen und ihr habt noch die zweite
Möglichkeit die finde ich persönlich ein
bisschen besser und zwar ist das die
kalte Führung das heißt das kommt
einfach so wie es ist in den Kühlschrank
für einen ganzen Tag also für 24 oder
wenn ihr richtig crazy seid sogar für 48
Stunden dann kann der Teig richtig
langsam Aussehen und der schmeckt
dadurch auch noch mal ein bisschen
anders also ich habe es mir ein bisschen
einfach gemacht ich habe es einfach
vorbereitet gestern schon und somit
konnte mein Teil heute bei kalterführung
also im Kühlschrank für 24 Stunden gehen
wenn ihr jetzt allerdings gar keine Zeit
hat gibt's noch eine dritte Variante
dann einfach die Hefe Menge verdoppeln
ein bisschen Zucker mit reingeben habe
ich euch alles in die Infobox und dann
nur 30 Minuten gehen lassen also solltet
ihr wirklich überhaupt keine Zeit haben
könnt ihr das auch machen so und wir
sehen uns dann gleich wieder dann zeige
ich euch wie ihr den Pizzateig
verarbeitet wir machen jetzt die
schnellste aber auch leckerste
Tomatensoße für Pizza dafür braucht ihr
wieder nur vier Zutaten ich nehme hier
Tomaten aus der Dose
frische Tomaten nehme ich tatsächlich
nie weil die Tomaten aus der Dose ja
auch erntefrisch konserviert werden da
kommt jetzt aber frischer Basilikum mit
rein Salz und frisch gemahlener Pfeffer
das ganze dann einfach pürieren und
fertig ist die Soße
so der Teig ist mega aufgegangen komm
mal bitte kurz dran so
der ist ultra ultra elastisch und der
kommt jetzt entweder das könnt ihr auch
wieder entscheiden auf einen Pizzastein
dann empfehle ich euch macht den Ofen an
auf volle Pulle Maximum was geht also
manche Öfen können bis 260 Grad meine
kann es 300 Grad den Pizzastein dann
heiß werden lassen und dann später die
Pizza drauf schieben ich habe jetzt hier
ein ganz normales Pizza Blech das ist
hat das gleiche Material wie auch meine
ähm wie mein sorry
das hat das gleiche Material wie mein
Emaille Backblech das ist auch aus
emeile da gebe ich jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen Grieß unten drunter und da gebe
ich direkt den Pizzateig rein ihr
braucht jetzt kein Nudelholz sondern
einfach den Pizzateig rein tun und dann
mit den Fingern den Teig ausreiten
wenn ihr euren Pizzateig später besser
auf euer Blech oder auf euren Pizza
Stein geben möchte dann habe ich einen
Tipp für euch einfach ein Backpapier und
da dann das Gries einmal drauf verteilen
und dann einfach den Pizzateig
ausbreiten durch den Grieß könnt ihr das
dann nämlich ganz einfach runter
schieben und dann bleibt euch das auch
nicht kleben
so das bereite ich jetzt auch noch aus
und dann habe ich mich heute dazu
entschieden die zwei beliebtesten Sorten
zu machen also einmal Gewitter ganz
klassisch damit ihr das einfach ja in so
einer basic form habt und ihr das dann
zu Hause selbst belegen könnt wie ihr
möchtet und die zweite beliebte Pizza
Variante ist Pizza Thunfisch und ihr
könnt mir jetzt mal in die Kommentare
schreiben welche Pizza ihr am liebsten
mögt in der ganz ehrlich alle Italiener
jetzt einmal die Ohren zu machen ich
mag's ja wenn man Sauce Hollandaise mit
Brokkoli und Hähnchen auf eine Pizza
gibt mir schon recht es ist ultra lecker
aber ich glaube Italiener haben das
jetzt gerade nicht so gerne und Ananas
finde ich auch geil so ich mache jetzt
einfach mal weiter und dann wird schön
belegt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so ach so warum gucke ich da rein so die
zweite Pizza schiebe ich jetzt hier
einmal auf mein Blech
so das ist natürlich der Vorfeld Effekt
ne das ist ein bisschen was festgehalten
aber es könnt ihr ruhig auch mal sehen
weil eigentlich wenn die genug Grieß
habt dann kommt es richtig easy runter
dann noch einmal schön begradigen und
dann hier auch wieder erst die
Tomatensoße ganz wichtig dann den Käse
am allerliebsten Mozzarella weil Käse
kommt immer direkt auf die Tomatensoße
und dann den Belag den ihr möchtet das
ist jetzt die zweite Pizza da gebe ich
jetzt Thunfisch und Zwiebeln oben drauf
und dann bei heißester Temperatur bei
also ich habe hier wie gesagt 300 Grad
ihr könnt auch 260° nehmen so sieben bis
acht Minuten das reicht vollkommen und
dann könnt ihr wirklich eine Pizza nach
der anderen in den Ofen schieben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schöne Pizza
ein bisschen spannender finde ist jetzt
die Thunfischpizza weißt du was davon
hallo ich habe ja wohl noch ein bisschen
äh Möglichkeiten hier auf dem Kanal ja
was soll ich dir sagen wo also das ist
so von vom Teig her weißt du was wir
beide auch dieses lecker der hat auch
Grieß unten drunter gehabt eigentlich
hilft es ja damit das nicht klebt aber
ich finde dass dieser Grieß auch was mit
also es ist Mundgefühl ist einfach
richtig gut richtig heftig Leute
hausgemacht frisch und lecker
aber irgendwie auch dann du merkst wie
das ist nicht so richtig ausgemacht ne
obwohl es eigentlich richtig gemacht
und vor allem geht's auch recht schnell
natürlich die Uhrzeit und so weiter klar
aber man sieht rein nach sieben Minuten
ist die Pizza fertig und man kann
wirklich so viele nacheinander
reinschieben richtig lecker Leute macht
unbedingt nach wir würden uns jetzt mega
cool
10:50 Uhr
also privat nicht auf Youtube oder aber
hier ist echt
steigert sich ja auch und ich habe euch
am Anfang auch gesagt ich habe wirklich
mit der Zeit raus
Funden was damit der Teig perfekt ist so
wir gehen uns jetzt noch wünschen euch
viel Spaß und Nachmachen und sagen dann
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]